[Music]
that the money people make is the
measure of their contribution to the
common good
but this is a mistake
you ended up with this kind of
technocracy which
presents itself as anti-politics but
which is actually politics that is in
the interest of the status quo
[Music]
i think increasingly people are inclined
on every side of political debate
to imagine that they speak for the
people that they
have a monopoly on legitimacy
well welcome everybody as all these
debates are this is
a very uh topical issue stories to
believe in
and the question of ideas and ideologies
and politics
i think in the first half of the 20th
century obviously that was a time of
grand political ideas didn't entirely
end well
but the later years seemed to move
towards a more managerial approach a
pragmatic
political culture of effective
management
now though it seems that idealism is
coming back
so it's taking a variety of different
forms from tribal nationalism to radical
socialism
or environmental activism whichever it
is
the goals and ideals and politics do
seem to be back
center stage so how should we think
about this
should we reject this return to idealism
as a vehicle for dangerous fantasies and
a warning sign of future turmoil of
conflict human misery
or is idealism central and necessary to
politics
and the shift back to idealism perhaps a
sign of hope
a necessary antidote to bland politics
that only really
serve the ruling elite well i'm joined
by
an extremely distinguished panel and
with
long experience in these issues grace
blakely is an author
who writes about economic policy and has
actively campaigned
for a corbyn led labour party her new
book the corona crash how the pandemic
will change capitalism
explores the coming economic fallout
from the coronavirus
the celebrated michael sandell teaches
political philosophy
at harvard university and has been
described by newsweek
as a rock star moralist his legendary
course
justice was the first harvard course to
be made freely available
online and has been reviewed by tens of
millions of people
his new book is the tyranny of merit
what became
of the common good rory stewart a former
diplomat
former mp author and politician who
catapulted himself into the uk political
limelight
when he became one of the uh country's
more unusual and recognizable
politicians capturing the attention
with his center ground campaign for
conservative
leadership so we are going to ask
each of our panelists to address their
attention
uh in the first instance to the question
that i um that i posed as to whether we
should
uh reject the return to idealism
as a vehicle for dangerous fantasies
michael would you start us off please
well thanks so much
isabel i think it's certainly
true that on the face of it
public discourse uh has
uh seemed to be about narrow managerial
technocratic things
and this inspires no one and when
passion does
enter it comes in the form of shouting
matches
where people shop past one another
without really listening
i think this has made for an empty
hollow
unsatisfying public discourse
citizens want politics to be about big
things
including questions of values
and i think the discontent that's
afflicted politics and democratic
societies in recent
decades has been a frustration with this
empty public discourse
i'm not sure though that this empty
public discourse doesn't conceal
a certain kind of well you could call it
idealism or
set of political ideas that are implicit
that govern politics beneath the surface
without open public debate
and those ideas i think are flawed
i would identify two one of them
is a certain kind of market faith even a
market triumphalist
faith the the conviction
that market mechanisms are the primary
instruments
for achieving the public good that's
been an idea
hovering just beneath the surface of our
seemingly technocratic managerial
politics of recent decades
and there's a second which concerns me a
lot and which was the subject of
my new book the tyranny of marriage it's
the idea
that those who land on top the winners
of the global economy uh
the the idea that they deserve their
success
that they've done it on their own that
their success is the measure
of their merit and that they therefore
deserve
the bounty that a market society heaps
upon them and by implication that those
who struggle those who've left
been left behind must deserve their fate
as well this is the dark side
of meritocracy that i write about in the
book so
i think it's a mistake to assume that a
seemingly technocratic
politics the one that has predominated
in recent decades
doesn't conceal a certain
kind of moral dispensation that kind of
attitude and ideology even toward
politics
and i think only now we're beginning to
surface it
to confront it and to debate it openly
as we should
michael thank you very much so it may
have looked managerial grace but there
was
an ideology concealed just below the
surface
um just to return to the to the initial
question
is this uh return this overt return to
idealism something that we should
reject it was pretty dangerous last time
around
i think the way that michael just
addressed that point to suggest that
what appeared to be a kind of
technocratic or managerial politics was
actually
politics in the interest of a certain
group cuts to
the heart of the appointment that i
would like to make which is that you
can't really have idealism
without some understanding of
materialism um
and the i think that is really what has
left our politics over the last 40 years
and it was much more present
prior to that and so kind of what is
materialism well if you contrast
idealism and materialism
there are two ways of looking at history
one suggests that history is driven
forward by ideas by debate by people
kind of you know changing their minds
about things and therefore institutions
changing
the other one suggests that history's
driven forward by kind of
by you know technological change by
economic change by basically things that
happen
um to the structures that kind of uh
that
you know predominate in our lives and
that that's why institutional change
happens now on the second view which is
not particularly dominant we live in a
very kind of idealist society
in that sense we kind of very much
center ideas in our political discourse
we don't think so much about class
anymore indeed it's become very
unfashionable
to think about class in recent years um
because
a kind of central theme of of that kind
of materialist reading of history
is that particularly when you look at it
from a marxist perspective history is
driven forward by conflicts between
different classes
and the politics is about overt conflict
between those two classes
over resources um and the story of i
suppose the kind of pre-financial crisis
period
is one where we were denying the
existence of those class interests
and therefore ended up with a
technocratic managerial kind of politics
which was
which presented itself as a
way that we would be able to discover
the common good it was all about i'm not
ideological i only care about what works
that was the view that was presented to
the vast majority of people by our
politicians and yet
most of the time because of the
ideologies because of the narratives
because of the
um the you know the the nature of the
work that these people were drawing on
because of the nature of the interests
that
uh were aligned behind them the things
that worked often ended up being the
things that actually happened to be in
the interest of the ruling classes so
you ended up with this kind of
technocracy which
presents itself as anti-politics but
which is actually politics that is in
the interest of the status quo that
serves to reinforce and support
the interests of the groups who are
already kind of you know in charge
and most powerful in our society and i
think that's really what we've seen a
backlash against in recent years it's
the realization that what was presented
to people you know we got the end of
history moment
ideological politics is dead instead you
will hand over power to
a set of politicians who uh will you
know
look seek out the vote of the median
voter you know the average person in
society
and they will thereby put forward
policies that are of the most benefit to
the maximum number of people
that was the view that was what we all
put into and then we realized in
during the financial crisis and in the
period since then that the policies that
we were told
were based on you know uh
consideration of the common good we're
actually more based on
an attempt to kind of promote the
interests of some people over others
even if actually promoting those
interests i mean you can think about the
way in which the financial sector was
consistently deregulated
actively harmed the interests of the
majority to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas